dann könnte es auf der wir sind schon
mal folge 15 des anwaltes together
für so ein flame einzelne dem soonwald
märz um 20 uhr
aber hier nur nein nein können wir
pennen gehn oder darf ich ein kompendium
rechtlich schon längst krieg gehört auch
moment gleich alter titel schlafenszeit
den das geht jetzt richtig geil aus der
weg der sg licht ähnlich will
weitermachen thema vorausgegangen die
bäume letzten mit so vielen folgen
gerichtet ich auch nicht aber lassen wir
aber so stehen ja gut hast du noch
irgendein thema oder jetzt hier ein
thema dabei ist dann auch die letzte
folge weil die eine folge macht der die
ganzen themen die andere folge zu den
themen raus und so weiter jetzt bin ich
wieder dran den ball schlimme ständig
unter zeitdruck stehe
du hast hat es jetzt anders eine stunde
540 minuten haus zu bauen ja dann gibt
mir ressourcen
doch dabei die zeit reisen in das sind
wie viele folgen werden nur noch mal ein
display 1 3777 folgen sollte man schon
hinkriegen haben wir abgeschafft oder in
sieben folgen wir sind bestimmt schon
wir haben insgesamt schon bei folge 20
oder so was wir sind
sieht schön aus wir sind bei dem grand
slam auswahl aus dieser sicht gucken
könnte es auf der wir sind schon mal
folge 15 deshalb ilham bei welcher folge
15 ganz genau
15 wären hier folgen alleine für topshop
media es lieben mit spark
das ist offiziell wir alleine der box of
7 mit spark spox trotzdem lief er mich
werdet ihr eigentlich los ist als
problem
spark wir beobachten dich ob du hier
bleibst nicht auf den leib
egal was wir erwägen wenn wir mehr an
wenn wir weiter mit anderen gästen
aufnehmen bleibt ackermann im
hintergrund im hartford immer ist das da
hinten leicht ja das ist so etwas wie
folgen den roten oder blauen world der
quoten das ist es und wir das haus ja
fertig bauen nach der aufnahme noch wenn
ich jetzt nicht tun sollten oder stimmt
das können wir machen
nein die idee du musst ein strauß aus
meinem haus heraus aus deinem haus
hey was fast wasser ich bin gerne fertig
holz das auf kreta postaufkommen schwert
größe sieht nett was wollt ihr lieber
von mir selbst einmal rauskommen gruppen
ich soll gucken was denn jetzt dreht
sich um guckst du nach oben
du machst als alles aus glas hier aus
glas pains oder aus normalen platz wie
du willst
wie hoch soll denn dreiecks für mich
gehasst fall kohle aus ach quatsch
ich weiß die besten 30 wieder ein
oder wollen wir so können wir
theoretisch die zuschauer fragen wollte
er dass wir gäste mal total lange zu
gast haben damit er auswendig haben oder
wollt ihr mehr so wirklich immer neue
gäste aber dafür dass die gäste dann
nachher offline austria haus fertig
bauen oder irgendwann mal wiederkommen
oder irgend wann mal wiederkommen aber
darauf dass audi den zehn milliarden
baustellen rumstehen des hauses von
zerbombt weil ihr schon so zerlegt habt
die baustellen
mit von crafter villa und park und die
baustellen schaut mit botschafter und
dehner und spielte später la la la la
bonheur hin und her kommentare stellt
euch die neue seite bekämpft vor hinter
den folgen wir komplett andere meinung
haben jetzt richtig beim thema geld auf
einmal die schafe sind fertig zum
wenigen themen könnt ihr über das
schreiben ob ich so ernste themen source
petit überbevölkerung der erde ob ich so
was überhaupt gefällt oder ob wahr oder
oder sohn einig wie zu seiner baustelle
waren wohl dann jeder gast ein kommt der
muss ein halbes haus begriff sind daher
baut mehr wieder sofort rausgeschmissen
wir warten was soll ich noch machen ich
wollte ach ja ich wollte den steil
weiter bauen keine offiziell keine
hobbys wolltest du jetzt nur ein thema
haben oder hast du selber ein thema ich
wollte noch ein thema hast du selber als
wir sehen die themen ausgegangen ja ich
hab noch eins dann schieß los müssen wir
ganz kurz
haben wir da haben wir wie stellt ihr
euch eure zukunft vor das eiskalt so
locker gefragt dass ich denke also das
linchen danke an das linchen stellt euch
eure zukunft vor also also allgemein mit
beruf und ob wir später noch youtube
machen und so meinst youtube denkmal
schon als hobby gibt es eben auch so
lange es geht wirklich hobby bestimmt
weiter also falls ja ob es noch in zehn
jahren noch so ist nah aber ich meine
youtube-clips hat auch erst seit lass
mich rechnen die pro sieben jahren 2007
und verbaut oder du bist also ins chaos
das die youtube hauptberuflich machen
kannst ja aber da muss man dann wieder
gerüstet ob man das in zehn jahren noch
so aussehen kann weil das wollte jetzt
auch sagen wer gut ist die sache als
wassers muss jetzt ja nicht sein
minecraft sein seminar der täter nicht
allgemein um minecraft es geht der
allgemeinen ob das so beibehalten wir
dass youtube bestimmt oder du hast halt
dann so eine große community dass du
eine eigene plattform gründen kann sage
ich jetzt mal den punkt tv.de ist es ja
schon bei franck ist zum beispiel schon
passiert er hatte schon frank de luca
rankommt con de bestimmt schon vergeben
di domenico bremen.de gibt's noch nicht
voll punkt de ich habe aber kein
interesse daran in die websites machen
weil ich damit überhaupt keine zeit
hätte die ganze zeit zu darum zugang der
als vollzeitjob nach der schule was ich
mache ja da habe ich auch keinen bock
dran
ich kann zwei youtube immer noch zudem
bei machen aber ich kann auch jederzeit
auf feld und ich glaube dass es auch
ganz gut wenn man wirklich jederzeit
sagen kann
irgendwie macht das keinen spaß mehr
erhält man erst mal auf wenn man nicht
sagen muss ja ich wusste jetzt
weitermachen weil ich das von beruf
macht uns griechen kein geld das finde
ich jetzt nicht so toll wurde kannst ja
alles möglich man muss ja nicht bleiben
was machst kannst experimentieren
rumprobieren ich glaube dass da so
schnell langweilig ja aber ich würde
sagen wenn ich wirklich irgendwann mal
sage okay gut ich meine stell dir vor
rom hat so urplötzlich sage ich mal
keine lust mehr
der müsste es trotzdem weiter 5 oder
commander krieger oder die müssen sich
halt neuen job suchen das war ja auch
bei minecraft sven so der youtube
hauptberuflich gemacht hat und war dann
arbeitslos die zeit war kein kanal hatte
dann hat er jetzt diesen neuen kanal da
gemacht dessen name ich bin mal in
rubicon bamm bamm bamm bamm dass ich
wenn mein kräften den oder so er ist mit
nach macht irgendwann die borussen oder
so darum rubicon da seine firma
irgendwann rubicon genannt weiß ich
alles so genau blick auf seine server
damals gespielt habe und da als youtube
partner wurde und da gesagt ja ich
musste jetzt eine firma anmelden und die
ovi kompromiss so firma damals ist das
jetzt auch so genannt weil complicated
complicated kennen nur negative
geschichten da diese zeit haben
eigentlich noch
ich bin hier vor den stress gerade du
hast auch fünf minuten und ist ob sie
wüssten die wand da vorne sonst
überhaupt mann er ist der riesige farben
schon denn ich weiß vermehrt sie auch
hoffentlich müssen wir mal mit weizen
durchlaufen
naja hab ich gerade schon muss er den
helfen bisschen ja ich finde bisher
betreibt ihr könnt euch dass er einfach
immerhin die schafe geholt weiß dass das
für eine arbeit weil ich bin der rächer
auf 23 folgen dann darum gelaufen und
die kurswechsel hätte ich genauso machen
wer die crews weg den kollegen die weg
bis das hinbekommen du ich nicht und es
war zu ich lasse jetzt erst mal wieder
ein paar leute bauen
also wer hier partout kein passt ein
paar leute ich lasse ein paar leute sich
paaren lanka schafe
diese seco bestätigt
ich verstehe das nicht wie kann es sein
dass park wie kann es sein dass die kuh
weges wird sagen da die man hunger
gehabt
auch dabei soll jährlich getötet nein
ich war nicht ich hab doch jedoch 27
schnitzel
ich hab sie nicht getötet ich glaube
bombay dollar wolle haus irgendwo so
viel wolle
oliver lemmer level von ersten wie gar
kein jetzt haben wir zu viel höher
gott so die recht machen und einfach
einen schönen see und am ende der straße
es wird nacht oder ssl douglas nach vier
minuten war ich doch umbringen hier ja
ja sonst nicht umsonst die killer joe
dimaggio die kirche das ist die
baustellen show the view kletter show
das auf jeden fall nicht so martina was
nicht mit deinem haus los hält der
forscher fragten fertig naja also die
runde form steht fast
egal da will ich sagen wir bauen das oft
spielt eine weitere folge kann ich nicht
aufnehmen wegen internet unsere also
jetzt macht er doch klaus ist sorgt dann
ein kollege loch fällt keine glasfront
sondern es ist einfach ein großes
fenster okay ist doch sollte man das
fenster soll den tick größer sein ist
etwas fertig der service komplett für
dich so schön dafür jede menge
inneneinrichtung ist heißt es in die
mitte aber ansonsten warte ich spontan
hier das sei auch ein döner pat bradley
drin
bei mir haben alle döner betten beim
einem döner peg peg
so schön so ein schönes haus ich konnte
die orange wolle orangenbäumchen leid da
will ich aber nicht schlafen in der
römischen wollte weil das in die götter
ich sauer dass sie den aspekt geklauter
aus dem tempel dass ich nicht gut die
götter die ich das sage ich jetzt nicht
noch mal so ich wollte erstmal unsere
nerven gehen kurz moment ich bin nicht
die bäume hier wechselt wird die bäume
ab gefällt also ich hab gedacht das ist
eure holzvorrat ich hab doch gesagt
nicht abfällt das ist doch dekoration
ich hab ja doch mal bitte ich brauche
bei mir
wieso bauen wiederum die settings sind
uns gut noch irgendwas voll schlecht
gerade ja irgendwas ist hier falsch
ob es in den fehler fehler regnet jetzt
die ganze zeit monster ist egal ob in
berlin oder nicht und auch wenn man
steht geht der regen auch weg ehrlich
wäre das pendel guten argument moment
meint vorne sekunde
ich wollte gar den see hin bauen
beziehungsweise gleich wir wollten den
see bauen ja also dem merke ich auch
schöner denen ich bin gespannt
rostocks danach hier dinge ins ende
machen
entente wo bist du denn wenn ich in
deinem haus also von mir aus ein part
geht auch noch aber dann müsste wirklich
fertig werden ja okay wenn dabei ein
partner okay versprochen ist versprochen
und wird auch nicht gebrochen
die antwort ist wichtig im bett da kann
ich aber ganz kurzen neues thema für
gleich raussuchen
ich helfe ihr sogar das bad noch und
baut wein bettfertig was willst du mein
bett fertig bauen ja stimmt kommt sid
golf resort für mich schon ein bisschen
dass es mit orangener wolle um zeuthen
druckplatten draufgelegt
sean penn gehen
das doch eine nacht muss darin schlafen
geht dem appell
hmm naja ich schon drin
gute nacht träum von raupen paradies
träumen von sparky dass er das sie mit
spa display macht ich dachte schon er
tagelang dort kommt der regen ist immer
noch da der regen ist immer noch weg sag
ich doch das erregen weg geht ja wie ich
es gesagt hat wie ich es gesagt hat du
hast gesagt hätte was ich und ich haben
eine deko ist meine rolle